[Music]
no one here
is not a dreamer
not in a world like this
where you can have it all
we live with Miracles that are
fingertips got robots taking out the
trash we fly into the stars and that's
what I want for you and your families
that's the dream you all deserve
soon you folks will be saying wow
I love living on the moon
foreign
remember we're not just selling we're
changing lives congratulations on your
new home in the Stars
I've been thinking about moving up there
the moon might be nice
what about all them aliens well there's
no such thing
what is this what's going on do we do
something wrong
gonna tell him soon what do you think I
am I know what you are you're gonna rip
him away from everything decent everyone
else plays fast and moves why can't we
what
[Music]
music can't stop because we get to Dream
On A Better Tomorrow
I want the truth
what are we selling here
I can't fix our problems
[Music]
we'll find a way you and me
there are some things you should know
about Jack
and you're brighter tomorrow doesn't
start when you land on the Moon it
starts today